domestic arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room cold
water is also available in the breakout
area outside the meeting room if the
fire alarm should sound please leave the
meeting room by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the Ipswich Town
Football Club training page please do
not use the atrium stairs to exit the
building do not re-enter the building
until you are told it's safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent I'd like to remind
everyone at the meeting that this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet and would be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this room you are
also consenting to being fulfilled by
the council enter the possible use of
those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and/or training purposes so
we turn to the agenda and the first item
on the agenda is apologies and
substitutions good morning we are all
here
are there any declarations of interest
by councillors none thank you the
minutes of the meeting held on the 8th
of journey which is just last week tell
us what's happening with those please
yes yeah and the minutes that we had
originated on the agenda have been
deferred to go to the meeting on the
20th of February and instead thank you
very much
are there any petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
please none receive thank you are there
any questions by
and are there any questions by
councillors please receive thank you so
we are straight on to item number seven
which is the draft general fund budget
for 2020 21 and that the full year our
clock so we're just scrutinizing this
draft budget the purpose is to give
feedback to cabinet to assist in their
deliberation at their February meeting
prior to the full council meeting on the
27th of February and I believe counselor
John White Eddie's going to introduce
thank you yes Thank You Jen
yes I'm pleased that our viewers greatly
have this opportunity to review the
draft budget with project going to
cabinet and then full council in
February and look forward to your
observations those in my group will know
I spent more than an hour presenting the
budget to them earlier in the month and
Catherine and Melissa and they were
given a similar one
it's November briefing you'll be pleased
now I'm not going to take up an hour of
your time in the introduction to now but
I wouldn't say I'd like to highlight
some key points you had a deliberate
policy of minimizing the use of new
homes bonus in balancing our budget over
the last few years and indeed none of
the run of our actual annual are out
terms since knew her as bonus started
have taken a penny from neurons bonus as
part of our normal council running costs
and the 2021 budget likewise uses no new
homes bonus to balance the books I think
if you look at paragraph 8.10 and the
graphs in there I think that clearly
shows why it's important because new
house bonus will fall away to zero by
2020 324 we also all know that the
central government support grants have
fallen away over the past few years so
that's why we've been determined that
our council can stand on its own two
feet generating our own income support
our own expenditure how are we doing
that or various pool investments
giving us income streams we're building
up zip code 250 million pound per
council by investing in secure real
estate assets with quality rental income
streams coming in we grow our tax base
each year but from the new house of
housing provides at least 1% or more
each year to our council tax base then
of course we've been having below modest
below inflation increases each year this
year proposing a 1.6 percent increase
which is 2 pounds 76 a year for a Bandi
property so a typical person or
household in the banding property paying
by direct debit over 10 Stallman's would
just see the power share of the council
tax going up by twenty eight pence per
month the budget for 2020 21 shows a
healthy surplus and that's even after
setting aside to two quite large sums 1
billion pounds ohm and a half million
pound so the million pound were putting
to a commercial development risk
management reserve this is for our in
district developments on our brownfield
and greenfield sites that's the middle
school sites at needin market
headquarter site and the large gateway
14 commercial site see none of these
things the risk free development never
is you just ask the busted a Kirlian
about that so I think it's best to have
some extra continuously put aside whilst
these are underway half a million pound
they're putting aside the climate change
initiatives I was pleased to sit down
before Christmas with the opposition
groups and they've produced several
thought-provoking and interesting
proposals and these were passing to
climate change task and finish group for
scalping and then to officers for
refining developing and implementing of
course talk is always easy but real
action needs real money so here's a half
a million pound as a starter and more
can come from the Jeff
growth efficiency fund going forward
should it be needed I'm talking of the
greater efficiency fund that's one of
the many earmarked reserves we're
spending but reserves in total should
still be thirteen million by the end of
2021 they're all set out in paragraph
seven point six and in that figure out a
way of ignoring SIL because that's
special and ring-fenced
but don't you agree that it's great to
have these health financial cushions
going forward whatever we want to do
where they want to invest our leisure
facilities help business development or
perhaps projects that are still a
twinkle in the eye of many of our
forward thinking and innovative officers
when he is there should have been it but
it's needed the report in French view
also covers capital all the details in
Appendix B twelve million were intending
to spend to include the balance of Cisco
the Needham Market Lakes visitor center
and leisure center development and
lastly within the recommendations we
propose to change to reduce the 25 cent
discount unoccupied and unfurnished
residential dwellings from three months
down to 28 days that brings in more
council tax tax as an incentive not to
keep properties vacant but I believe it
still gives landlords time to rillette
their properties so I think they're the
key things I wanted to just bring
everyone in my introduction
obviously we're happy to answer any
questions you may have on the report
thank you thank you can I just ask about
that you said the tax base is going up
year on year seems to have reduced this
is on in table six page 16 reduced for
the coming year unless there's a
typographical error there but with page
16 it goes down from last year eighty to
whatever they are unit 18 they please in
brackets they're actually all positive
right six-eight it starts you like there
at six million or thirty five grown to
six point two to six point four to six
point six to six point eight rounding to
the nearest
no I'm looking at the last but one line
the lump loan before the the total where
it says growth in tax base the 8270 six
is there a growth of 76 or is that the
growth each year yes it's going up by
seventy six it's going up by eighty two
it's going up by eighty four that's
that's right I mean if you take six
million in percent of that is sixty
thousand yeah so anything over sixty
thousand but less than 120 is somewhere
between one and two percent so basically
somewhere in that one welcome I mean
whisper in my ear it's 1.3 this time
that it's generally in that sort of
right just know things don't range thank
you any questions
oh sorry yes carefully like to add a bit
just just to add to that about the tax
base yes the extra income we're getting
for 2021 is lower than 1920 because the
tax base isn't all about just new homes
coming on it's the level of discounts
and exemptions that are there as well so
there's lots of adjustments that happen
to the numbers so yes
mid Suffolk has had another year of
quite good homes growth it's not the
only factor that affects the tax base so
although homes might be going up you
could still hover a slightly lower
increase in your tax base extra income
because of all the discounts and the
exemptions so people pay less in essence
and I guess the discounts the further
into the future we go the more difficult
is to predict the discounts thank you
anyone else right who would like to kick
off with some questions please Jeff
Cassar Caston
I am so you said it's them below
inflation the tax rise is actually below
inflation where would you see it in sort
of real terms for a homeowner in mid
Suffolk would you would you say that
it's there actually is staying in the
same place or you know if that's below
inflation right obviously inflation
there is month on month the December's
figures actually we just came out
yesterday and RPI yesterday for the 12
months to end of December was 2.2
percent that's a very latest update
figure I mean you can debate whether the
CPI are RPI but RPI is the retail price
index people are spending and so at one
point six six certainly it's payable to
there and I think looking back over the
years even when we've put it up by two
percent inflation has been higher than
that last couple years so it really
means in real terms the people are
spending less on their mid Suffolk
portion of the council tax caps Llewelyn
Thank You chair and I've got a question
on the the reduction in council tax
relief for unoccupied properties I was
just looking at this and thinking that I
suspect the majority of unoccupied
properties unoccupied unfurnished
properties or where someone has died and
I'm not sure that the length of time
that the properties are not keep I can
really be compressed much when you've
got things like probate and and and that
sort of thing to deal with so this this
change
I appreciate that it's gonna bring you
some extra income buddy he does look a
little bit like a death tax on families
and beneficiaries of people who've died
are just less a concern I had right I
don't have statistics in front of me in
terms of where and you know vacancies
arise I do know that a lot of
increasingly the private rental sector
is taking up more and more people and we
short-term Tennessee's up to six months
or 12 months there is quite a turnover
so the certainly if you look on things
like right-wing Fripp's witches
tremendous amount of properties always
can wreck coming up for rent
obviously the the probate side we've
been looking into this because it's
there are some releases which perhaps
Kathryn would maybe get yes hold thisis
a she's nothing ahead if Katherine can
tell us a little bit more around yes
I've just got actually got some
information from Andrew Weil cocking the
shared revenues partnership and a
property is exempt
when a person has died and then it
depends when so you get grant of probate
or letters of administration and the
exemption does continue for six months
after you get the grant or the probate
so our discount then applies at the end
of that that exemption period so there
is a reasonable length of time to give
people to sort of fares ad
thank you anything else
counselor Ellen counselor skull thank
you Jeff
and just a question on Table seven which
is on page 17 under assets investments
we've got the photovoltaic panels the
cost of servicing and repairs at
sixty-five thousand as an extra cost
pressure is this an escalation of the
cost of maintaining these always that
you say something else to me insofar as
its next roof cost pressure then by
definition it's that it isn't it's a
nation X sorry you know it's an
increasing cost when you're on the last
and I think that's because them I think
the PV panels well okay upon my hometown
date for Gavin if you wants to give more
detail thank you Jeff good morning
everyone
just in relation to solar PV panels we
have had a number of discussions at
previous cabinets and open scrutiny
about the PV program I think it's fair
to say that we've been on a journey with
solar PV over the last year and actually
what we've achieved in last few months
is actually really secure confident
numbers in the delivery of income which
is based on a whole range of variables
and that's been free working with an
external organization who's been
supporting us and the finance team to to
be able to really understand and project
that income over the lifetime of the
panel's some challenges that we've had
with the panel's themselves are as a
result of repairs being required and
unfortunately some of those repairs are
quite costly the inverter which is one
of the main parts of system has failed
on numerous units the unfortunate
element is that the two companies that
manufactured those inverters have some
been liquidized and therefore we've got
no recourse to claiming any of that
money back through warranties or or
anything else as a result they are
the repairs for 500 pounds of time that
we have to put in place but free working
with a specialist solar PV contractor
who also provides services to the County
Council on all of their assets we are
now also looking at different options in
terms of the repair and renewal of those
systems by using different types of
products and different ways of managing
the system so we are trying to mitigate
those costs I do expect to see those
reduce over the the forthcoming year
another example of that is that we
currently service the system every year
give it a full service actually there's
no legal responsibility for us to do
that the reality is that we can do a
lesser inspection each year and then do
a more a more systematic service perhaps
every five years which were game would
would reduce the servicing cost so whole
range of variables but I can reassure
you that there's a whole all people work
going on at the moment to reduce that
cost just another question on Table
eight for cost savings in income you've
got the grass cutting of SCC verges
obviously I understand that mid Suffolk
do it more often than Suffolk County
Council actually require and this came
out in the briefing the other week so
there's a figure there as well but can I
make a plea that in particular we've
urges that are close to junctions that
we perhaps look at that because whilst
it might be more acceptable to cut less
on long stretches of Road near
particular junctions it can be an
accident potential so it might be that
we need to be a little bit you know
careful about where we actually do not
know I quite agree that from my own
experience at Junction 52 on the 814 the
roundabout there that there are times
where I've been cursing out how the
grasses thank you any anyone else any
questions
counselor field did you have any
questions you'd like to ask sorry but
it's time did it that's the end of the
question I have a couple of things
really just sort of as some more
strategic level the new Hung's bonus
you're telling us is is disappearing and
obviously in the past as we all know we
lost basic grant from the government and
it was ones laptop always goes off for
the long time and one lost the the basic
ground he was replaced with something
that was incentivise which was new homes
bonus you know now telling us a new
house bonuses kind of comes an end which
since the number of councils haven't
used it for anything a particular dis -
tea in the bank is not that surprising
but wonder do you have any guidance or
the replacement cuz I find it slightly
difficult to imagine that the government
is gonna willingly get lots of district
councils in trouble by cutting their
budget quite substantially and this
would be a quite a dramatic cut in the
gross sum of money we're receiving so
while I understand you're being told
that this is going to end
is there no guidance of where it's going
to go because my concern would be that
we you know we're doing all this to meet
the needs of residents of various types
we're not you know just not spending
money cuz spending money is evil we're
actually spending money to good purpose
particularly not in Karen's area I guess
so what is the real feel on that new
hands bonus is it go disappear you
should have employed it's gonna be
replaced with something else do you have
no guidance at all this - what that
something else might be and what's the
value I lost at first but I'll also been
defer to Catherine because I think she's
got her ear to the ground through the
the great volume I mean my first
thoughts when this all started coming in
we each see from the table on page 15 it
started way back about eight years again
and it was building up and it just
looked like an amazing source of money
which
one point Italia said well it's gonna be
two million quid a year but forever that
like the way it was sort of building up
on a six year rolling basis and it just
seemed to me that it was replacing a
sort of grant we got for for no good
reason other than just existence where
they incentivize grant as you explained
so I was it was so easy at that stage to
think well this is incentivized money
which as long as we do as the incentive
wants us to do it'll it'll be there but
they the rules change it went from six
years to five years to four years a top
bottom slice point four percent of the
growth and then the most recent thing is
this latest year is just a one-off here
and we're told it's going to stop in
twenty three twenty four so when assumes
on one hand it something should replace
it but on the other hand this or mood
music which Kaffee might not think
expound on is that District Council's
are pretty low on the government
priority because of the unitary in
county concerns with children's care and
social care so you know I don't know we
don't know what's going to come but it's
prudent to think at the moment that
until here more perhaps not a lot of
coming but the provisional settlement
that we had just before Christmas gave
us the information about how new homes
bonuses going to phase out but it was
only really headline information in
terms of there will be a housing
incentive but they will consult on what
that will look like I think the only
thing they mentioned in the settlement
was that it would somehow be linked more
to planning decisions I mean they have
talked about linking new homes bonus and
the levy you get around planning
decisions and whether they're on appeal
or not but that is all the information
that we have had so far from from the
government
I mean in terms of you say some some
councils use it and some don't
there are probably more at the district
borough council level that are using it
to support their their budgets but I
think possibly what the government may
be thinking is because they're
signalling now that it's going to phase
out over the next three years that gives
councils long enough to adapt their
financial plans to be able to
accommodate it by the time that it has
gone so I think there will be something
what it's gonna be based on how it will
be shared out I'll have no more details
at the moment as Council of white heads
suggested district councils we don't
seem high on the government's agenda in
terms of funding at the moment and the
current split of new homes bonuses that
district councils get 80% the County
Council gets 20% if there is an
incentive they could change that that
split and that make up between between
the two so it feels very unknown at the
moment hence I haven't felt able to even
try and put anything into the numbers at
the moment we obviously know new homes
bonus for 2021 and he is beyond I think
as we get more information from the
government during 2021 and we can
estimate what we think that might look
like for us in the future years or doing
during next year but at the moment I
just haven't got enough information to
even hazard a guess as to what we may or
may not get in future yep thanks that
means you're going to have ninety five
grand Civic surplus at the end which
obviously is fairly small just looking a
bit further on you talk about full
review of business rights is it seemed
obvious from the noises from the high
street and things that business rights
are crippling a number of small
businesses at the moment and you know
one might anticipate the government
might do something about that but you've
not put anything at all in the budget to
to
business rates dropping substantially is
that a best judgment issue or guidance
issue again we've been partially prudent
I suppose in terms of not increasing
business rates because there usually is
an inflationary increase in the baseline
that we that we put in our in our
budgets we only get to keep a small
proportion we get to keep about two
million pounds out of the 16 or 17
million that we collect in total so if
there is a huge impact on on business
rates than other parties bear quite a
bit of that brunt as well as ourselves
obviously the government takes 50% of
business rates the retail sector is
obviously just one part of businesses
where we get business rates income from
so it's not all of our of our business
rates and what the government had did
announce in the Queen's speech was that
they are extending some retail discounts
there is a retail discount scheme at the
moment and we had proved a policy
cabinet approved a policy last year and
they're extending where businesses get a
33 percent discount at the moment that
will be increased to 50 percent they are
going to include pubs in that retail
discount now but it only will apply to
premises whose rate or value is 50 1,000
pounds or below so this sort of
threshold further for the bigger so I'm
being cautious by not increasing but
equally retail sector is only part of
our business rates base and the
government is trying to support the
retail sector through those discounts
and where they offer the discounts they
actually compensate us but a lot of
being comes through a section 31 grant
so we get income back back from the
government when it's something that they
do nationally so taking the cautious
view of keeping business rates at a
fairly flat level again until we know
or about what a review might look like
and where that might go it to be honest
I'd say it's a bit of a concern because
the government is pushing more and more
of our funding towards business rates so
if they're going to fundamentally change
the system what does that mean for us
and our finances because they are making
us more and more dependent on that on
that source of income but again it's a
we'll have to wait and see and they've
given no indication yet as to what
review may look like thank you for now
obviously the one thing we have got
control of these council tax which none
of us like putting up but you may notice
the the police and crime commissioners
putting up four percent the county is
just stuck tax out four percent and
yours is a really tiny portion of this
time well might argue that caution might
be to increase a little more there and
not rely on the things that are not
under your control but unless anybody
wants to comment on that well you're
aware that the we've got the 2% ceiling
or 5-pound but the just looking at it
from 2% point of view compared to one
point six six us
I think council attacks 1% brings in
about 60,000 give or take so then from
one point six six to two which is a
third of a percent would only raise
another 20,000 in the whole scheme of
what we're talking about now and
millions of pounds of new homes bonus
and business grants and everything the
castle tax variability that we have
within our control obviously we could
reduce it any amount but they are
sealing that increasing is two percent
or five pound so it's not really a lot
in our control
thank you are there any other questions
Casa Caston
so in relationship to homelessness
reserves that the funding for
homelessness comes directly from ma CLG
they obviously have invested heavily
nationwide in tackling homelessness with
the aim to reduce and eradicate rough
sleeping and also that's on the back of
the homes reduction Act in the last 18
months two years so they have
historically provided two forms of
funding the new burdens funding which
was to support councils doing
homelessness duties differently was due
to end but the government announced just
before Christmas a revised funding
stream so that funding is now going to
come in officers are already planning on
how that that money will be spent and
obviously there's a number of new
initiatives coming forward over the next
few months to support not only prevent
and support homelessness and rough
sleeping but encourage people into into
the housing market through private rent
and and so on so though a lot of that
reserve is already earmarked in terms of
cost of staffing and new products and
services that we can offer Thank You
councillor mother
Thank You chair and it's a question on
capital investment in Cisco obviously it
says in the report that the interest
rate that the public works lie on board
charges is gone up if we're drawing down
further funds for Cisco in the future
are we paying that the new right how
does that come out yes when we fix new
long term loans then it is at the at the
current rate and we do quite a lot of
our borrowing at short-term breaks at
the moment because it's obviously
cheaper that the long term so it's at
the point we think that we need to
perhaps fix into some longer-term loans
to give us that stability if you like in
terms of what we'll be paying that's
when we pick up the you know the pwl be
right as it currently stands and yes
there was an increase this year we had
been using assumptions that were not
down that a 1% below what the PWB put up
it we'd been sort of bit cautious in
terms of those longer-term rates so the
1% hasn't added an extra 1% to what we
were assuming in terms of cific o income
but it has had a you know sort of a
marginal impact on our figures moving
forward so when we move from short-term
into long-term that's obviously when it
it has the impact on whatever the rates
are at that point in time so I can't
just come back with it and so what
you're saying effectively that there's
no significant impact on the business
case for Cisco thank you I've got just
three specific queries on table 7 just a
lit asking for an explanation of just
three of the figures that are in there
the first is the gateway 14 limited
there's a big figure in brackets there
of seven hundred and twenty six thousand
pounds is there a reason why
that that that's a big figure there and
also the the other two are under
sustainable communities the planning
appeals in the joint Local Plan
examination cost I presume they're just
one offs those two if you could just
clarified be grateful please well you'll
see that in terms of some of these cost
pressures including the planning's
appeals there this is a nice under
percent funded from reserves in other
words we will participating those
appeals and we've put money aside in the
past and now as as it's being spent it
is a cost pressure but it's coming out
of reserves in terms of the gateway 14
the cost pressures showing there apart
from in twenty one twenty two way you've
got the negative seven negative pressure
there was a saving of 726 perhaps
release are all Catherine between them
you can just put a bit more bone meat on
the burners it's all to do with gateway
14 in terms of when the development and
the build is going to happen on the site
so as gateway full team will start to
develop that site they will take more
borrowing from the council's and where
mid Suffolk benefits in that is the
differential between the rate at which
it can borrow at and write it is then
lending on to gateway 14 company so as
the capital expenditure and the
requirement to take more loans from the
council increased as during that that
peak development period then the income
benefit to mid Suffolk goes up and
you'll see the later years you start to
get pressures come along and that's when
obviously development is tailing down
and the requirement for loans reduces
because as the site will be developed
plots will be sold off you know
developed and sold and then the
requirement for loans from the from mid
Suffolk will reduce so you see they're
sort of reserved
in trend in terms of that income thank
you can't forecast it this time and say
we've got parking been decriminalized
and that's gonna be run by West Suffolk
and dipswitch
um yeah I can't see a lot accounting for
any legal costs or any um anything of
that nature in there does that mean that
we're going to do it without spending
any money or how does it work could you
just explain I'm afraid I'm not an
expert on the CPA in how it actually
works one thing we do just need to check
with Cassandra Clare and Susie assistant
director whose area that comes under is
whether we have got what we need in the
budget for next year now know that we've
got a date that it's gonna be
implemented from because we know it's
now going to be in a six of April but it
will come in from so one of the things
we do just need to double-check before
we finalize the budget and bring it back
in February is to make sure we've got
what we need in the budget around CPA
I'm afraid um I'm not an expert in that
area so I don't know exactly how the
arrangements are gonna work with with
with Western Ipswich thank you so other
any more comments is that a yes or no
cares the field
right okay Oh counselor field yeah a
couple of things wanted us to continue
with our CPA question at the moment I
mean my understanding is most civil
parking enforcement councils use their
off sleep parking revenues as well as on
street parking if you have that sort of
thing because clearly the revenue from
fines is not adequate to support the
activity and I know that the county's
putting in the on certainly the on
street parking revenues from Barisan
Edmonds and Ipswich into the pot
initially to make sure the startup is
smooth and that's around a million
pounds I think
and so just question will the parking
revenues from stone market or someone
have to go to subsidize it which is
activity or does your even with them say
they'll they'll fund everything out of
fines so that's one thing you want to
answer that and I'll come back to my
next question I think based on the
earlier question that I haven't got that
level of detailed knowledge around CPA
so I would need to go them to seek
advice and I can come back to you on the
answer with that one I would have
thought it'd be really interesting for
the committee to make sure we will
understand what's going to happen so
some of us get asked questions obviously
parish councils the other one was just a
question about utilities or notice in
paragraph 17 you say general inflation
utilities nearly crease somewhere
lighter in the housing budget you put in
five percent on the utilities for
sheltered tenants in sheltered
accommodation the odd ninety seven year
olds are fairly rich but that does seem
a bit rich it might get that by rare but
the other question really in there is
the county is assuming an eight percent
increase
in utilities certainly in the
electricity charges so there seems to be
a set of mismatches here in the
decisions or wondered and that's just
different in the general fund we don't
have a huge amount of properties that we
pay the utilities obviously know sitting
in endeavour house we pay rent and
service charges to Suffolk County
Council and we you know we know what
those figures are going to be so we
don't have in the general fund too many
other properties that are subject to the
variations of utility costs but what we
also tend to do is what we tend to ask
budget managers if they have got some
increases in that area to actually work
out how they can absorb it within the
budget that they've got it's not to say
it's not an area that we have lots and
lots of utility budgets so we ask them
to be creative and think about how if
they have got an increase what else they
can do in their service area to you know
to control those costs in is the overall
envelope that we give them in terms of
their budget so just in relation to
service charges in childhood for the use
of utilities they propose five percent
increases based on actuals rather than
any assumptions it's actually virtus
that manage our utilities on on our
behalf so also they're always actively
looking at market in terms of the best
provider and the best price in what we
do in terms of shared housing service
charges in relation to utilities is we
take the overall cost and then we
distribute that across the schemes so
that for example where sites may be more
expensive due to their location or due
to the type of heating facility actually
that cost to spread across the shared
housing service likewise the benefit in
terms of solar PV which we have on some
of our sites actually spread across the
housing service in terms of that that
benefit over this specific scheme so the
5% is based on actually
creases are there any other questions or
comments
does anybody have a view on what you'd
like might like to propose what message
you might like to send to officers and
to the cabinet we've had a fairly full
discussion of it there are lots of
questions and answers
is there anything beyond something like
asking offices and cabinet to take
account of the comments made in drawing
up the next version of the of the budget
the draft the draft budget for
consideration of February cabinet
meeting would something around that sort
of wording be how you feel about a
proposal nobody want to add anything to
that would anybody like to propose that
cancel them all right okay
their recommendation these are the
recommendations that are going to
recover them for cabinet members to vote
on so I don't think we can we can we
can't actually vote we could well we can
we can say that we've generally happy
but we would like them to take account
of our comments because I think I think
it's important that they do take account
of the comments that we've made in in
enjoying up the next version of the
budget things other things are moving on
in stages there were comments made at
cabinet which offices and and the
portfolio holder will be taking account
of similarly the comments made here so I
I don't if you something are on ask
offices and cabinet to take note of the
comments made at this meeting and
drawing up the draft budget for
consideration at the February cabinet
meeting cancer field committee want to
welcome the provision of half a million
pounds for environmental actions which
seems to me a good thing to do show some
force so I thank you for that suggestion
would catch them all would you like to
add that to your
so it's a million times better spread
over two years isn't it right so I think
as it stands now we welcome the addition
of 1 million pounds over the next two
years we need some words therefore the
to tackle to tackle climate change for
measures to tackle climate change it can
I just say in terms of this budget
looking at now we've committed half a
million right and we are saying with
sort of giving assurances if that 1/2
million isn't adequate then on basis of
the sort of levels of reserves we've got
then I'm not saying this guy's a little
bit but yeah well with sensibly we can
go beyond that half a million cases are
made but I was you know beyond 2021
we're not gonna draw the line at 1/2
million and say no further but the
moment we're not you're not committing
to a whole million as your wording seem
to imply so we will welcome the
additional half a million pounds to
tackle climate change during the year
2021 and ask ask offices and cabinet to
take note of the comments made in
drawing up the draft budget for
consideration at the February cabinet
meeting so we've got proposer we've got
a seconder
are we all in favor thank you very much
thank you very much everyone who's
attended and contributed we next move on
to the the next item which is the draft
housing revenue account the HRA budget
and the four-year outlook and again our
purposes to get some feedback to make
comments on on this on this budget on
this paper the core
for consideration by officers and
cabinet so counsel why today you go to
introduce this again I'll try to be as
brief as I can and I think all members
of scrutiny said letters have been
around for some while well know that the
housing revenue account has faced a
number of challenges over the last few
years and quite a few of those and now
we've been looked at in detail in
scrutiny and on the face of it looking
at the budget next year there's a budget
deficit of six hundred and twelve
thousand more expenditure than income
coming in so that might suggest that the
challenges are indeed continuing but I
think we must not ignore the many
positive developments and improvements
that have commenced during this current
financial year and paragraph 7.1
explains the fundamental review of the
housing services has been undertaken
this year it's identified savings
efficiencies an income generating
opportunities to achieve as an ongoing
sustainable business plan and lots of
details behind that or in Section seven
and eight of the report so I said what
draw that to your attention to start
with it may be that one of the headlines
that come out of this report is the 2%
2.7 percent increase in council tax oh
sorry yeah council house rents
I mean councillor Caston just speaking
about inflation earlier but I think we
need to put that into context you know
the last four years the government
imposed a 1% annual rent reduction
year-on-year and bearing in mind that
the has a moving account its main source
of income this council rent incomings
yeah that has had a an impact
quite a substantial impact but put it
all in perspective a council house
tenant who was paying eighty pound a
week before all this started back in
April 16 with this full lots of 1% and
then this 2.7 coming through
that 80 pound rent would would change
over those five years to 78 pounds 90 -
so basically paying less after five
years despite this 2.7 cent inquiry so
why you just take that into the hell
consideration beyond the castle house
rent increases we're keeping garage
rents at the same level the paper can
friends view suggests that sheltered
housing service charges were increased
by two pound a week although we are
doing a more in-depth review of that at
the moment but the principle being that
the sheltered housing should not be
cross subsidized by non sheltered
tenants we already talked about the
utility increases of 5% we thought all
these are set out in the report we must
not lose track the fact this HRA budget
includes a marked increase in new build
and acquisition program the capital
costs of that are in Appendix A over the
next four years 44 million pound is
anticipated to be spent and the book
that actually is in the first couple of
years and that money's kept large so
money is coming from a combination of
capital receipts grounds borrowings and
revenue contribution and again appendix
a has those details working with
external providers it Seany
we anticipate that would equate 185
laudable homes and 85 shared ownership
homes with major sites such as the need
of markets still market middle schools
as well as our former HQ site car park
and we feel that's great news for young
people and indeed for anybody in
Mississippi that's struggling to find
housing at the moment it's all this
boring obviously comes at a cost and
borrowing levels are shown in paragraph
6.3 but once debt peaks at 2022 it does
fall away quite steadily in fact it has
over 15
period and of course behind all this
current year's budget is a sustainable
30-year HRI business plan which we
produce on a rolling basis to ensure
that the plans got long-term
sustainability that's really all I
wanted to say thank you who'd like to
kickoff somebody must have a question
I've got two or three questions or just
points of clarification the service
charge as properties become D sheltered
I think that that is still carrying on
the properties are being detailed if
we've got say a unit an overall service
charge across the whole of the district
does that mean that as properties are
Dashell turd the cost per tenant who is
still in sheltered accommodation goes up
and is that part of the reason for this
increase do you want to deal with that
one first and I'll come on to the other
ones Thank You chair I'm basically in
answer to your question yes you're right
as the number of shared housing units
decreases obviously there are still
costs that are incurred in terms of
managing that service and as a result it
is likely that the overall cost per
shared housing resident does increase
that's a fact
other factors have been that over the
last two three years actually we've seen
a number of additional costs in that
service in providing it so for example
we're carrying out more Legionella
testing now than we were a couple of
years ago there's a cost to that as a
result of the tragic events of grenfell
and the focus on fire
we're doing more work around fire risk
assessments more remedial works which
ultimately makes tenants safer in those
homes and that's a real positive but it
is having an impact in terms of the
additional costs of providing that
service so I think long-term we do need
to look at that service again we need to
revisit the the review that took place
some some three four years ago and ask
ourselves some questions about
how do we deliver that service in a
meaningful way in a positive way that
provides the services that that older
people need but in a way that it is
cost-effective for them as it is for us
and a piece of work that I'd like to
embark on over the forthcoming financial
year is a review of service charges per
se that's not just sure would have some
service charges that's the opportunity
to charge us for charge for general
needs in terms of maybe communal areas
in where blocks of flats are present as
well as service charges for temporary
accommodation which we have as well so
we're gonna possibly be looking at a
review of all of those charges over the
forthcoming year if I just make the
point to follow that one I would be
concerned if staffing levels for
instance award ins had to reduce in
order to balance the books because I
think with visiting wardens that that's
more or less in terms of numbers as low
as it can get from what I'm hearing from
from people living in sheltered
accommodation but that's a comment
that's not really a question do I do
have a question about I mean it's great
that you've got new build and great you
there will be acquisitions but there
must be some revenue and staffing
consequences of of these extra
properties that we eat there'll be extra
income but I guess there'll be extra
staffing and how does that all balance
out please okay so it responds to that I
can't confirm that of the hundred plus
properties that we've already acquired
or built over the past four years and
the program of activity over the next
four years actually we are solving all
of that cost within our base staffing
budget and actually over the past couple
of months we've been on a review of our
housing service and we have made or we
are in the process of restructuring
those teams I think in the views of
going on today
in fact in relation to to some of those
changes so we are moving in terms of
what we need and what we require and as
a result that's a reason for the
restructure in addition we're also
focusing on things like for example
and the star survey results that we got
in the summer of last year which gave us
a really clear picture of what tenants
and residents were telling us about the
services that they receive or not don't
receive and as a result some of those
restructuring proposals mean that we
will now have going forward and
neighborhoods team focused on communal
areas and focused on estate improvements
they're signs of that work already
starting to really support residents to
have an environment that they feel safe
and happy in and I'm pleased that we can
develop those type of services as part
of this review just follow that with one
last question so that's an improvement
in service but you don't anticipate any
extra cost any extra resources so as
part of the management review we've
actually reduced in the level of
management capacity within the housing
service as a result of this current
review were actually moving the resource
around tailoring that what we need
finding new unitive ways of delivering
service without that that requirement in
in terms of man-hours which gives us the
opportunity to deliver these new
neighborhood team as an example that's
at no course that's that's balancing it
out broadly on a zero Thank You
councillor Caston getting to turn my
microphone on um we expected the garage
uptake to increase it didn't what did we
think was gonna happen and why didn't
there
thankee comes forecasting they're really
good questions are ones that I've asked
about myself over recent weeks actually
what we have is a report coming forward
to administration later in January which
reviews and provides a review of that
that garage service what we found over
the past year is actually we've had
staff leave and we haven't yet recruited
because we bring over a review so we had
some had some staff vacancies but what
we have
being able to do is we have cleared the
waiting list so anyone waiting for a
garage where we have supply has a garage
anyone on the waiting list now is in
areas where actually we've got more
demand them then we've got supply rolls
reverse we've got a number of sites
where we've actually got supply but
we've got no demand and as a result we
are currently working with our assets
team in terms of identifying those sites
and we hope to bring forward some of
those schemes over the next year in
terms of possibly redevelopment or using
those sites in a different way and I
think as part of that work going forward
some of the questions that we're going
to be talking to portfolio holders and
cabinet about are can we find in it if
ways to provide the charging in terms of
reduced of course where the supply what
the demand isn't there as well as ask
ourselves a question that we assume all
of this income we're not getting it as a
result of no dibond so actually rather
than continue to continue in that vein
actually do we need to consider perhaps
demolishing some sites and and just
turning that over to additional car
parking which we may lose an income but
we'll certainly eradicate or resolve
some of the parking issues and just
weighing up some of those that some of
those factors in terms of that work so
there's a report actually going to admin
briefing next week to summarize some of
that work any councillor Mellon Thank
You chair and I've got a quick question
on capital investment and new-build
paragraph 11.3 talks about the the to
middle school sites which you know about
and the former council offices you need
a market and it mentions the site of
Elms well and can you tell me a bit more
about that and how many houses are
predicted for their thanks councilman I
can't give you a lot of detail what I
can tell you is that we have a pipeline
of new build and development some of the
sites that council I hadn't mentioned or
ones where we've already got planning
and expect to be on site shortly we do
have a piece of land at M as well that
is
has the potential for future development
we don't expect to bring that forward in
the next two years we expect that to be
a longer-term aspiration in terms of
numbers I can't give you numbers or say
we're not that far forward in terms of
planning it might be a sight due to its
size that we actually want to to develop
in in a slightly different way possibly
with some marker sale or shared
ownership or or some social housing as
well but that that's some way off yet
but it will be some assignment it's
obviously being worked on over the
forthcoming months sorry that's a site
that we already own or we've bought it's
a piece of HR a land that we have in our
asset portfolio cows are hurting thank
you
so is this bike on the graph see on page
34 is that for the middle schools what
would walk them councillor Mellon was
just talking about and the the old HQ
the spike on you know years 21 to 22 yes
so it will be those sites that you've
just mentioned council having him there
will be other sites we're actually
bidding on a large number of
opportunities there are a number of
section 106 opportunities in mid Suffolk
we've actually been successful on two
schemes this week we've heard from the
developer yesterday so that that program
of activity we're looking at at not only
the that the ones that we will know
about them and we've had in the pipeline
for some time but other sites as and
when we get presented with opportunities
any other questions okay well it's
really a comment rather than the
question but on the income and savings
opportunities obviously I see that the
remove of the decorating vouchers for
new tenants to save three thousand
pounds that has also had potentially an
effect on other bodies I serve as a
trustee on a charity within stone market
and we've already started to see
applicants coming to us for help towards
decorating costs of properties which we
are at the moment for
feeling and but we are slightly
concerned that it might lead to an
upward trend in due course everything
the council does whether it be carpets
or whatever has an effect on another
body within the area so it's just a plea
to be what's it's a small amount of
saving it could potentially have an
impact on other bodies and their funding
just just a plain reading yes I can
understand that and also I think if
somebody's moving into a new rental
property and they're given or offered
some vouchers to carry out some
decoration perhaps they would look after
the property better if they knew that
there was that little sum of money that
would help them along the way so yes I
felt it's a pity that that was being
withdrawn casa feel yeah perhaps I could
add to that you know cherry filled what
is in my division as well as simply
disco in my County Division I'm well
aware there there was a young lad who
were moved in into what had been
sheltered accommodation was sleeping on
the floor
didn't have any furniture whatsoever all
carpets so the local elderly residents
investors combination club together and
bought him some stuff so he could
survive whether that's the right thing
to be doing another question can I to
try and move to questions can I just ask
the the CPI plus 1% increase gets to 2.7
percent the last time we were on that
game
we were told don't worry about it all
the residents claim housing benefits at
all the poor residents claim I was in
benefits the ones that are owned decent
pensions it's no worry so don't worry
about that sort of increase is not a
problem and the government saw let's do
it and as well as a awful lot of other
local authorities and they told us good
game that puts our housing benefits
now put the rents down one percent per
hour
please for four years I just wondered
what the risk is that by going straight
from a negative increase to you know a
positive increase which is 1% above of
inflation is provoking that sort of
response again they you you will be told
to put them back down again by the
government which is somewhat more
powerful than we are I think I think
that's one for you counsel Whitehead my
understanding is as I said before it was
a statutory obligation to reduce by 1%
and what they also believe now that the
the same not guidance but statuary
requirements set out till the next five
years I think until 2025 this CPI plus
1% and I've beyond that we've got no
further guidance but we are using I
think CPI after that
Thank You Jay um just to come back and I
will answer that question in a minute
but just come back to to cancel a fear
its statement in relation to the
gentleman cherry fields we did all Slee
stop doing stop providing decoration
grants that was to save some money and I
appreciate that that may present some
challenges but we hit we've actually
seen void times reduce and we've not
received negative feedback from
prospective tenants or new tenants and
actually what we're doing is the same
now as a number of housing providers in
the east of of England in relation to
Karpis we've never provided carpets for
someone moving in if we find through the
void process that there are carpets
there and they are in good condition
we'll try it wherever possible to retain
those and and in terms of furniture
unless the person's moving into
temporary accommodation where we have
some duty to provide certain fixtures
and fittings we wouldn't provide
furniture as a rule of thumb however we
do have a 10 C support team and they are
very active in gaining grants and
support for new tenants
as well as existing tenants and I would
encourage members if they find
themselves with a tenant in that
situation to contact that team and I'll
ensure that that team are aware of this
conversation but actively they are
getting referrals and they've actually
bought a lot of income additional income
into the organization as well through
supporting tenants in relation to their
their rents moving on to the question
our counselor field raised it is a fact
that we've we're proposing this increase
obviously that is on the back of a
significant deficit even with that
increase this year and without that
increase that deficit would be even
bigger and would even have a greater
effect on our reserves and yes it's
correct what council White had said
about the reductions of 1% over the past
four years
and the fact that tenants in the
forthcoming year will pay less than they
did did four years ago the some of the
challenge that we face are trying to
manage their housing revenue account and
work with members is is actually we try
and forecast the budget over both five
years and over thirty years so as and
when rent reduction was was announced
and came into force actually we'd been
projecting rents increasing by maybe two
three four percent a year so so in that
regard actually the basis of the
business plan was probably predicated on
rent being maybe twelve thirteen
fourteen percent higher than they are
now and that's why you can see that
there are we facing deficits we're
facing challenges in terms of our
reserves and we happen to be creative in
terms of managing our costs but that's
on the back of investing more than forty
million pounds over the next four years
on new housing and that can only be be
something to celebrate
any other comment anything officers
would like to add can we say is that a
twitch or all right should I carry on
but I think Catherine's the Kathryn has
got something to add and then we'll come
to you counselor field I was just gonna
write something in the last point about
the rent levels I think I saw I think it
was only yesterday that the government
are going to increase the local housing
allowance the first time so benefits
should be going up in line with
obviously I was putting the rents up I
think they have been frozen I think for
the last two or three years I think but
they I think I saw yesterday an
announcement but that they're going to
do an inflationary increase on the local
housing allowance so that will be good
news for for tenants okay so what's the
tell us about the question on 5.6 it
says every new social home should
generate a fiscal surplus the rental
income and you talk about that's about
that's in after two other paragraphs
that talk about the the you to the wider
economy and saving in Housing Benefit
costs that new social housing cost
demonstrates as Gavin said just a minute
Carol what an excellent thing it is to
build building some new houses but just
add some fiscal surplus all I have to
say whenever I do this sounds I can't
might not add up whether we could be
provided perhaps with a brief analysis
that shows where I can't drive the
mortgage right count lighters properly
or whatever it is I'll do it if we can
certainly look at putting something
together and sharing that with you and
if committee vans
thank you right we'll move on to a
proposal is there anything specific you
would want us to say to cabinet and to
officers or are you happy with like a
broad proposal and as we did with the
previous item councillor Caston with the
addition what would the addition of
comments made yeah curse the mullet
right thank you are you happy that
you've got cleanup worthy thank you very
much
so is everyone in favor of that proposal
which has been seconded as unanimous
thank you very much
so we now move on to well there are no
information bulletins that would have
been item 9 item 10 is the forthcoming
decisions list I've had a look at that
and they didn't seem to be anything
within the forthcoming decisions list
anything new in there that we wanted to
bring forward to to the work plan so if
can we go signing him
so can I just ask to give them if we
could have a information bulletin or
short report from Heather is it
regarding the disabled facilities gone
and what they're basically there update
on how they're doing that thank you so
that would be under item 11 yes so under
item 11 which we'd like to add that I
just wondered there having been
questions about civil parking
enforcement whether at some point we
might
to have an information bulletin on that
now I'm not quite sure when that might
be but I think in view of some of the
questions that have been asked I think
we ought to know a little bit more or
have out in the open a little bit more
about how it's being managed and what
the cost implications are but probably
sorry Kosar casters I actually attended
the civil parking enforcement
partnership meeting it's in a very early
stage you know they're still trying to
work out exactly what they'll cover and
how have we done
I wouldn't think there's a huge amount
to report at the moment but they are
meeting again in well next month I
believe and something's obviously got to
happen by March so I think I think I
think it may a report may need to be to
come in in March because it's very
little to report on at the moment so
we'd like to scrutinize it before the
sort of 1st of April implementation day
rather than to review how it how
implementation went kalamullah
thank you I actually agree with what
term Kasich has no say so I think it'd
be very useful to look at it before they
start so we've got a clearer picture of
exactly what they're actually gonna be
covering this this part in your
forcement because it does seem to be a
bit of confusion at the moment from what
I'm hearing from various people that
sort of thing
so would we like we'd like to see that
at our March meeting would you be happy
with an information bulletin or do you
feel we need a full report personally I
don't care whether it's a an information
bulletin or a full report but I would
like so detailed exactly what they will
be covering under this new partnership
you know what they can obviously Park it
on your lives
parking injunctions but I think the only
one that I get a lot of queries on he's
actually parking on
pavements which is actually illegal
under the highway code so that sort of
things very useful telecasted just to
help councilmen are out there so parking
on the pavements will still be illegal
and we've still be covered by the police
but I think yeah the major issues is how
what sort of enforcement we're gonna get
as mid Suffolk and we know who's going
to well we know who's going to cover it
I don't know if anyone's seen the maps
where it's sort of split just above stay
market into West Suffolk from Ipswich
but I think the important thing for us
is to them to work out exactly what's a
mid stuff is going to have in their
parking enforcement and what you know
whether it's going to be proactive or
reactive enforcement and how that's
going to work and I think before that's
actually signed off and goes into the
practice I'd like that to come past this
committee so we can put to give it the
benefit of councillors knowledge well my
understanding is that if it was an
information bulletin then it's an
inflammation bulletin there's not it's
not a huge amount we can do with it but
if it's a report then we would
anticipate that cabinet member would be
here and and offices if yeah yeah as you
as a council having him says how how are
we going to add value we're going to go
through it and see whether there are any
bits missing out I guess so
can we do that through an information
bulletin yes I think the issue with the
information bulletin is you can't really
make any recommendations to anywhere so
if you if you ask him for a report to
actually want to take it further you
need a report rather than an information
bulletin however and it might be worth
just to the chairs having a chat with
the officers
we was involved with this and had yes
and also what authority have we actually
got to influence this one well I mean
that that is the pastor point with you
know we're like a consortium aren't we
oh I wonder if it might be helpful to
have an information bulletin at your
next meeting and then on the back which
which I recall would be in February
February is that right
and Henriette and and then you could
decide if you wanted and to ask for a
report on the back of that for the next
meeting which would be in March thank
you that's helpful with 20th of February
is the next overview and scrutiny meaty
it's a joint meeting do you think that's
the right sort of time I'm looking at
council casting and so yeah I think that
would be and we from that we can tell
whether what what we need to do I I know
the workloads gonna be fairly fairly
high for such a big deadline say we
don't we don't want to ask too much if
there's not a lot we can change about it
but I think if we can if we can do that
in the February meeting we can then that
information can get to our environment
portfolio holder and anything that can
be done can be done in the partnership
meeting even even if it's some not done
through the normal channels it will draw
attention to that to the our environment
portfolio holder so yeah I think that's
a really good idea so with in item 11 we
have we have the the work plan the draft
work plan so what we would be doing
would be well we've got we've got
planning enforcement down for 20th of
February so we would add parking
enforcement there as well as an
information bulletin and then cancer
caster sorry he's forehead I don't know
how we want to scrutinize this these
some climate change panel
recommendations because that is very
time sensitive as well I don't know it
looks like that's gonna be quite a big
meeting but I think in March
there'll be recommendations come out of
the climate change panel and I don't
know if we want to scrutinize them
before they go to cabinet or or how
you'd want to look at that mr. Chen we
there's been quite a lot of cross-party
strategy groups that we we don't
scrutinize because they are cross-party
so I don't if yes if the strategy's
going to full counsel could you leave
that with us and we'll we'll have a word
and if there is something that could
sensibly be brought forward say March
then we would say we'd share that in the
February meeting I wouldn't I wouldn't
want to put something into that into the
work plan if there's nothing because
it's a cross-party there's nothing much
we can add we can all have an input into
that strategy through our
representatives on that on the group so
I think only if it runs into difficulty
would we want to would we want to
scrutinize it and in any case as
councilor handing him I said it may be
it may be a political influence in which
case that would have to be through
through Council so what I was picking up
is the disabled facilities grants which
we haven't yet timetabled and wondered
if that was something for for my doing a
an information bulletin in May because
the new the new proposals that the new
strategy will have been would have had a
cup two or three months to have embedded
in we will get a steer on on how well
that or not that's going so so that
would be an information bulletin as well
so with those two additions and a
discussion around how to deal with the
climate change are you happy then
could somebody proposes that that forms
the new work plan that's councillor
handing and and and and council they can
Casa Caston okay item item 12 is the
favorite overview and scrutiny work plan
I think in respect about it it's almost
identical they've got one additional
item but of course at the next chair and
vice chairs briefing we will update our
favorite colleagues on what's happened
what we have added and that could well
well it will have an influence on their
work plan clearly if they don't
introduce the same items into their into
the joint work plan then we will be
dealing with those as a mid suffered
over the in scrutiny meeting which
really is pointless when they are our
items across both districts so we we
don't be it is only for information so
our next meeting is on the 20th of
February it will be a joint meeting 9:00
9:30 so with that there's nothing else
to add